[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça a découvert la
Réunion ensemble vous allez paraît alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
parle pas moins les misérables
au niveau de la toile des roches et nous
nous ça découvre la boucle basse
invitale tu connais c'est aussi un
espace naturel sensible allez
allons-nous
là-haut dans la forêt Bibou et aussi dit
salut tous les jours mon pantalon dans
la cour qu'on met la vrimement la vérité
un même au travail toutes les passionnés
pour mon mama mia cire ma bataille
s'ennuie
comment allez-vous bien ça va bien chaud
donc automatiquement quand on se
retrouve avec monter et qu'on a pas
d'entraînement on a chaud donc on fait
des pauvres d'accord et comment ça se
fait vous avez décidé de faire cette
balade aujourd'hui je suis ma fille mais
qui est beaucoup plus loin avec moi et
qui est beaucoup plus jeune que moi
forcément et vous allez faire quoi comme
circuit du coup alors votre si vous avez
dit c'est quoi le circuits aujourd'hui
une boucle qu'elle m'a dit c'est ce
qu'elle a lu dans le bouquin qu'on a
acheté sur la Réunion ah là oui oui on
n'est pas des locaux je viens de
Belgique alors pourquoi la Réunion alors
et bien parce que ma fille a des amis
qui travaillent ici d'accord elles ont
fait leurs études en Belgique et puis
elles sont venues travailler ici à la
Réunion et auparavant vous connaissez
l'île de la Réunion pas du tout
simplement via les documentaires c'est
tout bien sûr en tout cas merci
vous allez bien ça va et vous oui très
bien dis-moi vous faites ça en courant
vous voyez je fais des sortes et des
montées pour mon entraînement et
pourquoi vous vous préparez une course
ou bien juste pour le plaisir ouais
effectivement je prépare le la Diagonale
des Fous du Grand Raid d'accord et vous
habitez la Réunion non du tout je suis
arrivé il y a un mode dans le cadre du
boulot donc là je suis en déplacement
professionnel pour trois mois et là
depuis l'arrivée
pas trop quoi un petit peu mais c'est
encore compliqué il y a d'autres
sentiers à la Réunion pourquoi se sentir
chez moi donc j'ai pas besoin de voiture
pour me transporter ici d'accord après
sinon je m'aventure aussi au niveau de
dos d'âne à l'entrée de Mafate c'est sur
la c'est l'itinéraire de la course et
l'objectif c'est bien évidemment c'est
d'arriver à La Redoute oui si possible
évitez la troisième nuit bon ben elle
est bon bah bonne descente à vous merci
combien de remonter après encore une et
puis c'est fini bon ben on a trouvé
alors allez ciao bah merci en
[Musique]
Award
rien à la montagne
[Musique]
bon et ben du coup nous continuons
monter ah ben l'équipe arrive là oh là
là oh c'est bon monsieur bonjour Comment
va ça va bien ça va bien je vois vous
êtes nombreux là on est en famille vous
êtes en famille vous avez été où là bah
là en fait on descend bah c'est vital on
vient du regard d'accord et ensuite on
descend jusqu'en bas et puis après on
monte alors
et c'est une randonnée facile à dire
c'est c'est tranquille ouais et tout le
monde habite à la Réunion
et du coup comment ça se fait vous êtes
venu en vacances ici mais
rapprochez-vous monsieur
d'accord les amis sur place d'accord et
puis de la métropole c'est une
destination qui est hyper connue hyper
attirante il y a beaucoup de de beaux
sites de belles choses à voir et donc on
est venu ici deux semaines pour profiter
de tout ça
bonne descente avec grand plaisir la
Réunion
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène parle pas nous aller nous verrez
la même un peu de respect pour mon pays
il avait vraiment après depuis son lit
au bout de la terre dans le paradis pour
comprendre faut un de mon pays la
réunion nous les la même mais mon pays
comment il est la réunion sans même nom
allez nous verrez que la
la petite boucle pour arriver par là
alors oublie pas ici le bassin vital est
sur un espace naturel sensible et bien
pour être dans la thématique là il
prétend pas loin d'un abonné
[Musique]
autour des ruches et ben allons à
l'importance bonus abeilles là bonjour
madame comment il est les larmes
c'est un lieu où j’accueille du public
de la maternelle jusqu'aux adultes et
l'objectif c'est de s'initier à
l'apiculture et de rencontrer les
abeilles de la Réunion les abeilles qui
fabriquent du miel mais aussi les
abeilles solitaires qu'on peut retrouver
partout sur l'île concrètement
le bons abeilles comment il se passe ça
dépend de l'âge d'accord l'objectif
c'est déjà de rencontrer les abeilles de
se rendre compte qu'est-ce que c'est un
insecte à quoi ça sert sur la terre
quand on connaît on peut protéger on
apprend à aimer
pour protéger et là au niveau du jardin
pédagogique donne le miel quand même oui
oui donc ici ici c'est pas un rucher de
production d'accord les abeilles
produisent du miel et donc quand il y en
a en
grosse quantité j'en prends un petit peu
mais c'est pas l'objectif principal ici
l'objectif c'est d'apprendre à connaître
à découvrir et apprendre à aimer les
insectes je vois dans les collèges et
les lycées j'installe des ruchers
pédagogiques et ce sont les élèves qui
s'occupent des abeilles qui apprennent à
élever les abeilles et c'est important
de sensibiliser les jeunes dès le plus
le plus jeune âge sur l'importance de la
protection de nos abeilles effectivement
bon
vraiment intéressant ok la Réunion nana
gaillard a fait pour le temps visite et
tout ça a rendu la prochaine épisode de
l'émission nous cette fois-ci sera dans
la commune de Saint-Pierre et nous va
aller visiter depuis tout mon verre
gaillard semaine on trouve
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]